Bonjour à tous, aujourd’hui dans ScienceClic,
le système solaire.
Le système solaire est l’ensemble de tous
les objets qui sont soumis à l’attraction du Soleil.
Dans le système solaire, on trouve tout d’abord
une étoile, le Soleil. C’est de loin l’objet
le plus massif du système, dont il est le
centre. C’est autour du Soleil que gravitent
les autres objets plus petits.
Ensuite viennent quatre planètes à surface
rocheuse, qu’on appelle planètes telluriques:
Mercure, qui est la plus petite et également
la plus proche du Soleil.
Vénus, dont l'atmosphère très épaisse
procure par effet de serre une température
de surface extrêmement élevée, atteignant
presque 500 degrés Celsius.
La Terre, la plus grande des planètes rocheuses.
On trouve à sa surface de l'eau liquide,
et des êtres vivants complexes. Elle possède
également un satellite, La Lune, qui orbite autour d’elle.
Et enfin Mars, la planète tellurique la plus
éloignée du Soleil, qui possède
deux petites lunes : Phobos et Deimos.
Derrière Mars, se trouve une grande ceinture
d’astéroïdes. Elle se compose de plusieurs
centaines de milliers de petits débris rocheux.
Ces astéroïdes peuvent parfois quitter leur
orbite, et par hasard arriver sur Terre sous
la forme de météorites.
Derrière la ceinture d’astéroïdes, s’enchaînent
quatre planètes gazeuses. Les planètes gazeuses
n’ont pas de surface solide, ce sont d’énormes
boules de gaz maintenues autour d'un noyau
très dense par l’attraction gravitationnelle.
La première planète gazeuse est Jupiter.
C’est la plus grande des planètes du système solaire.
A sa surface se déchaînent des
vents et des orages très puissants.
Jupiter étant très massive, son influence gravitationnelle est très importante, et elle possède
plus d’une soixantaine de lunes orbitant autour
d’elle, comme Europe ou Ganymède.
Ensuite vient Saturne, légèrement plus petite,
et entourée de plusieurs anneaux concentriques.
Ces anneaux sont composés de débris de roche et de glace qui orbitent autour de la planète.
Saturne possède également plus d’une soixantaine
de lunes, comme Titan ou Encelade.
Elle n’est pas la seule planète à posséder des anneaux,
mais en revanche les siens sont bien plus
visibles que les anneaux des autres planètes
qui en possèdent.
Derrière Saturne on trouve Uranus, puis Neptune.
Ces deux planètes gazeuses sont plus petites
que les deux précédentes bien qu’elles
restent beaucoup plus grandes que la Terre.
Elles possèdent également quelques anneaux,
mais qui sont très difficiles à repérer.
Uranus possède une trentaine de lunes, tandis
que Neptune, la plus petite des planètes
gazeuses, en possède une vingtaine.
Les planètes rocheuses et les planètes gazeuses
ne sont pas seules dans le système solaire.
En effet on dénombre également plusieurs
planètes naines, qui sont plus petites que
les planètes habituelles, mais restent plus
grandes que de simples astéroïdes.
Dans les planètes naines on trouve par exemple
Cérès, qui est le plus gros objet de la
ceinture d'astéroïdes, ou encore
Pluton, qui possède
de multiples lunes comme
Charon, Nyx ou Kerberos.
Derrière toutes les planètes on trouve à
nouveau une ceinture d’astéroïdes,
c'est la ceinture de Kuiper.
Enfin, derrière la ceinture de Kuiper,
une multitude de petits objets, comme par exemple
les comètes, orbitent autour du Soleil formant
une sorte de sphère qui s’étend très
loin. C’est ce qu'on appelle le nuage d’Oort.
Bien que le système solaire soit aujourd’hui
mieux connu que jamais, il reste cependant
des controverses quand à sa limite. La définition
la plus commune la place juste derrière le
nuage d’Oort, car à cette distance l'influence gravitationnelle du Soleil n'est pratiquement plus ressentie.
Le système solaire ne se résume donc pas
qu’aux huit planètes que l’on connaît.
C'est un ensemble très vaste qui fourmille
d'une multitude d'objets encore à découvrir.
Comme ordre de grandeur, la largeur du système
solaire est au moins 100000 fois plus grande
que la distance Terre – Soleil.
Cependant notre étoile n'est qu'une parmi
des milliards, et il existe dans l'univers
une très grande variété de systèmes stellaires,
avec des planètes encore complètement inconnues,
et qui sait, peut être d'autres formes de vie